stéphane bern et son compagnon et youri
j'appelle youri des photos par
mois au début j'ai cru que c'étaient les
deux chiens qui posait pour leur amour
qui présentaient leurs maîtres et enfin
de ces traverses c'est tous les quatre
sont coiffés par ace et des rimes
non mais ils se connaissent depuis deux
ans et franchement il est maire de
beaucouzé mais moi j'ai un peu changé
répond je regarde un peu leurs
interventions leurs interviews ils ont
l'air d'être très proche ils se sont
même presque juré fidélité sans s'être
mariée à droite mais c'est comme s'ils
étaient mariés ils s'aiment d'amour
tendre à la spa du coin non non non il
faut que tu saches que vocia veulent se
rencontrer là c'est plus j'ai su à dîner
chez des amis à d'accord moi je veux
dire autre chose c'est que cette une qui
a été préparée comme beaucoup de sujets
de ce genre là pour des raisons
particulières et le téléfilm sur france
3 pour y assurer qu'elle joue un
commandant de la sûreté à une
communication qui était orchestrée par
stéphane et son entourage pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'il envisage
il a en tête parce que j'étais l'arrière
et maladies il a dit de façon très
claire il à dire vieille animateurs en
gros c'est ringard c'est sinistre par
contre un vieil acteur on dit qu'il a de
la bouteille donc en fait il est en
pleine transition donc être est ce
pareil pensé à appeler définir notre
pensée le partage il est dans une dans
une commission qui est très ciblé et
c'est cibler sa part a nommé après la
jolie franchement oui effectivement ils
se sont rencontrés ils ont trouvé
l'amour et son mec c'est incroyable la
city a ouvert un site tu sais ce que ça
ce site au crac oui deux rencontres
rencontres gay oui mais pour gay qui
sont foutus le tibet
c'est à dire
demande ce que ça fait comme études ce
que tu lis ce que tu m as que tu vas
dans les expos grand palais est ce que
tu aimes la
noix
j'aime c'est dommage parce c'est un peu
élitiste ça voudrait dire que des
personnes doivent être ensemble
uniquement sur le même niveau
intellectuel est ce que tu peux très
bien il sera un grand intellectuel avec
un gyan ne me sens
pas beaucoup parce que moi je pense que
au niveau mais en tout cas il ya deux
coups qui sont un peu déséquilibré c'est
pas grave alors pas tout simplement oui
benoît marcotte honnêtement je trouve ça
moins gênant ce site là que ryan ou cd
personnes entre j'en connais très très
riches qui rentrent en communion
qui sauteraient pour écrire je dois
mettre combien tu gagnes par mois sur ce
site pour accéder à ce site et faut être
parrainé alors toujours pour parler
bratislava je voulais rester sur eux
effectivement ils ont fait cette courbe
et le problème c'est que je veux dire la
vérité je mets vraiment j'adore stéphane
bern je pense que c'est l'un des plus
gentils chez duke et de la télévision
mais je me demande si l'équipe hull qui
soit mais tous très intelligente
devienne pas fou il a fait il ya cinq
ans c'est sa couverture de paris match
avec son mec et que je vais vous montrer
la couverture des sept voiles a cédé
c'est là donc c'était la même temps les
chiens c'est évident mais voilà ce qui
dit dans l'interview dans la nouvelle
cette couverture et un effet désastreux
que j'avais pas escompté elle a ruiné ma
vie privée et mon couple c'est violent
d'être exposé le mac est exposée ils se
séparent à cause d'une une de paris
match et tombe amoureux il refait la une
de paris match
il avait dit qu'il le ferait il n'y a
pas que la une de paris match je me
permets c'est à dire sur instagram de
youri il filme stéphane bern allons à
longueur de temps lui fait faire des
petites vidéos amusantes donc en fait
s'ils sont très très exposés sur
instagram de son compagnon vieux jeu
poursuit ce que je disais c'est de la
com à l'époque il avait été missionnée
par macron le président de la république
pour s'occuper du patrimoine immobilier
et ses maîtres en une espèce de loterie
nationale pour résumer les vieux
monuments etc et cette couv là à
l'époque faisait partie de cette
communication pour ça et d'autres choses
mais il n'a pas fait les choses par
hasard quand tu es une couverture oui
j'en attends maîtrise idée vraiment
amoureux et la dernière fois peut être
la dernière interview que c'est mon
compagnon n'aimes pas tu dis que tu
quoque quelques financiers j'ai pas
financier c'est c'est de la carrière il
veut devenir comédien les week
ends en parler tu fais les pattes au
début j'ai fait quelques
minutes 10 qui berce baird qui va dire
oui
je suis en train de dire j'adore c'est
comme si intéressé parce qu'une histoire
d'amour c'est beau l'amour aux îles et
la roma tous en même temps vous savez
par des téléspectateurs avec n'est pas
romantique je dis pas qu'il est par
moment si c'est tout et je dis pas qu'il
ait pas amoureux je dis juste que à un
moment donné il n'est pas le premier on
se dit bah tiens je suis amoureux mais
là si je présente mon couple moi
j'adorais tout leur sens j'adore tes
pairs mais vraiment j'aimerais
j'aimerais comprendre je pense que la
télé rend ton peu la dette et qu'elle ne
pouvait pas se blairer ayama sais pas ce
qui se passe dans son groupe elle peut
avoir vécu quelque chose avec cette
personne là ça s'est mal passé ils se
sont séparés et on sait pas ce qui se
passe un truc ou peut-être que même son
congé au compteur le une connerie de
punk caudry et alors on vit des choses
différents foyers des personnes avec qui
j'avais pas envie de m'afficher il ya
des personnels qui j'assume aujourd'hui
de m'afficher parlement aujourd'hui je
suis célibataire mais mon coeur est pris
à 6,2 me demander ma fille chérie
j'ai toujours été discret tout s'est tu
sais très bien que je ne faisais shooté
à mon insu parce que je ne voulais pas
chômé ça publiquement mis à part le père
de mon fils aujourd'hui la personne qui
est dans mon coeur avec lui je ne suis
pas si nous demandait d'officialiser les
choses je le ferai mais c'est ça peut
changer la donne que dans mon coeur avec
qui je ne suis pas ouais
chan tp people
ça rien de fou à ce que je dis monsieur
ben moi j'ai pas compris pas compris mon
nom mais c'est aux états dans le poème
c'est qui c'est un plan cul c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas pardon tu as un cross a un
coup de coeur pour quelqu'un essaie pas
partager lui mais féret stéphane
n'ont rien là bas je ne suis pas avec
lui on n'est pas ensemble c'est aristide
qu est prêt parce qu'ils n'aiment pas
lui à
témoin puisque c'est mignon j'ai peut
être un coup de coeur oui il est connu
non il est comme ça c'est arrêté les
tenues des thèmes capucine apte à donner
toi